it sort of went round like like gossip
on set because some people knew and
other people didn't
so it was actually like real life lady
whistle down gossip getting spread
i was also doing research online looking
at all the fan sites like creeping
around and i found it on a fan site
what i know that we have a shot that
appears to be a reveal but
who knows it was super under the radar i
mean
my jaw fell to the floor and then we
were like oh my god who is it
my name is lady whistle down
[Music]
you do not know me and never shall but
be forewarned
dear reader i certainly know
you
[Music]
what an incredible first season of
bridgerton
i was not expecting that we were going
to get to see
the reveal of lady whistle down at the
end of
the very first season nicola what was
your reaction when you found out your
big reveal was happening
so soon i mean my jaw fell to the floor
because i thought
not only i feel like they're going to
make it such an iconic moment but it's
also going to be so much fun
to do there's moments as an actor where
you're just like overly enjoying
yourself and i having
this like giant cape and the carriage
and it being so dramatic like it was
just
so much fun to do and i think it was
totally the right thing because
these books have existed for 20 years so
if you want to find out who penelope who
lady whistled down is
you can find it pretty quick so i
thought it was like such a sharp
smart move and i hope it's satisfying
for people to watch as it were for me to
film
well she does seem to be someone with
access who knows if whistle down is even
a she
fair point because she's simply too good
to be anyone but a man
we were all really surprised and then
slowly
like it sort of went round like like
gossip on set because some people knew
and other people didn't
so it was actually like real life lady
whistle down gossip getting spread
um but yeah it was super super exciting
when we found out who it was and
honestly like the the greatest choice
the greatest stories
and my god how brilliantly was it
performed by nicola i knew that
obviously through the books that um you
know i got tipped off that it you know
penny penny had some
ulterior motives going on there but you
know chamberlain and it's chris van
dusen so you never
you never know you can never never be uh
rest on your laurels no it makes
it makes sense but i my jaw did drop
when i found out me i trust no b
like i know that we have a shot that
appears to be
a reveal but who knows
could well be but no it's good fun and
it's great to kind of have a
jaw-dropping moment at the end of the
season
um so i think that's that's a treat for
everyone did you know from the very
beginning that penelope was still
gonna be lady whistle down or were you
worried that chris was gonna like pick
another character
oh i was i was really nervous because i
found out i was reading the books but
then
i was also doing research online looking
at all the fan sites like creeping
around and i found out on a fan site
when it said you know penelope's whistle
down and i couldn't believe my eyes and
i kept reading it thinking
something was wrong and then the
enormity of it hit me and i thought this
is huge and also julie andrews
is voicing it so i thought julie and i
are the same because the sale
was a whole thing but when i finally sat
down with chris
um i kind of i wanted to ask but i was
really awkward so i was like am i
on my arm is it i'm is bloody are we
still good is that
still yes it is you because you know
it could they could have changed it of
course they could have you know it's an
adaptation
so um but i think one of the things that
julia was pretty sure about was that was
staying as it was because it gives
penelope's character such depth and it's
she's so fascinating because she is she
is a young woman that contains
multitudes she's both shy
and she's really cunning and she is
loving but she can
you know absolutely ruin someone's life
if she wants so it was like
so much fun to play do not tell me that
is yet another scandal she this one is
different this one
this subject's my name so why did you
decide to reveal
lady whistle down at the end of season
one i think that's going to be such a
huge shock to the book fans out there
you know i think it was time honestly it
it you know
lady whistle down is such an interesting
device to be able to use
in the show and and with it being
penelope in the writers room we always
talked about there being two tracks to
the approach
of penelope as lady whistled down one
track would never penalties on screen
for
fans of the books and those that are
familiar with penelope
being lady whistlebound from the books
we needed to make those scenes
still fun and still interesting um for
those book fans and
learning and gleaning something new
about penelope and about lady whistled
out
and then there's also the other track of
uh people that have not read the books
and that are not as familiar with the
story and have no idea
what's up our sleeve so so it's it's
about you know
never being ahead of things and not
making sure we're not telegraphing where
we're going and keeping that mystery
alive and we had so much fun
crafting the narrative around penelope
as lady whistled down but i think that
at the end we wanted you know it to be
a satisfying conclusion and you know it
speaks to to everywhere we're going in
the future hopefully
in success did you ever think about
making lady whistle down a different
character so that it was a surprise to
book fans and non-book fans alike or
were you like
this is penelope we've got to stay true
we absolutely
explored just about every character on
the show as lady whistle down and what
that would mean and what that would do
to not only the season but the series um
you know we
explored violet we explored a lady
danbury we explored
eloise herself daphne herself we really
you know
brimsley the queen's assistant uh the
the queen's servant we had a lot of fun
thinking what if it was brimsley
um we explored all avenues well claudia
guess what i just got off with chris and
he actually told me that there was a
very strong moment when they considered
eloise to be lady whistle down did you
know that
no i didn't thank you though what
has anyone else read what lady wizard
has written of late
[Music]
do you think she has any clue that her
bff
is actually the most mysterious person
in london and how do you think she would
eventually react to this unveiling
i think she's going to be fuming but i
shouldn't be human
because the thing is right like she
loves her best mate but
it doesn't surprise me that eloise
doesn't realize that penelope's some
sort of secret mastermind because eloise
is constantly talking about stuff
so like she's like talking at like 300
miles per hour isn't she so of course
she didn't notice that her best friend
is a
genius so like i think
i'm not surprised that she doesn't
realize but also penelope hides it very
well
and i guess maybe eloise would think
that her mate wouldn't lie to her and
because i said
she wouldn't lie to her because it's not
very nice to lie to your friends
it's not very good i don't feel like she
ever lied you guys i rewatched the
season so many times
and penelope was always just kind of
like oh you're still searching for lady
whistle down i don't know
you're like twisting the truth is
different from lying
so we spoke about mine by omission yeah
yeah i mean it was mad because there
were scenes where i think because i
i have like me as nicola i have like a
really guilty conscience
so i like physically i'm not really able
to lie because i'll just like come out
in hives and i can't
so claudia and i would sit down with our
sides and i'd go
how can she not tell her how could she
not this is her best friend for her how
could she not and then
i often have to like claudia very
cleverly or wisely said to me you know
she's 17.
i think penelope has no clue of the the
power that she
is accruing um the effect it's having on
other people's lives but
i think it's going to be then the
disaster when i always find out i really
it stresses me out with the thought of
them
because we didn't like shooting the
scenes where we were arguing because we
love each other
so we didn't want to do it could it be
lady featherington
[Laughter]
you have yet to read what wizard our
rights of the featherington's little
sister
i don't want penelope's mom to find out
because as soon as she finds out that
penelope's sitting on all that cash from
selling these scandal magazines she's
gonna be like
well little daughter yeah
this is the things that i want these are
questions i have for christmas deuce and
i'm like
is it in her mattress are we like is she
buying shoes that she's hiding what
where what is that what's happening here
maybe she's got a partner
no see i know they i know things that i
can't say i know how she does it but i
just don't know what where the cash is
going
let it be known if there's a scandal
i shall uncover it
and share every last detail